VOICE
This July 4th, revisit the movie
that made blowing up American
landmarks cool...
VOICE (CONT'D)
...until 9/11... but now, 12 years
later, it's apparently cool again?
VOICE (CONT'D)
Independence Day.
A film that answered whether we're
alone in the universe, by stealing
from all the other films that
answered whether we're alone in the
universe. Featuring...
VOICE (CONT'D)
The premise from War of the Worlds
The aliens from Alien
VOICE (CONT'D)
The spaceships from V
The Dogfights from Star Wars
VOICE (CONT'D)
The statue of liberty from Planet
of the Apes
VOICE (CONT'D)
(And) the Jeff Goldblum from
Jurassic Park
VOICE (CONT'D)
To battle against an alien threat,
humanity's last hope is this rag
tag group of survivors:
VOICE (CONT'D)
Fighter pilot Steven Hiller, a
Fresh Prince of the Air, who says
cool things, even when there's no
one around to hear them.
VOICE (CONT'D)
David Levinson. A Jeff Goldblum-like satellite engineer...
And Thomas Whitmore: The best movie president ever...
VOICE (CONT'D)
Who channels William Shatner.
Prepare to stand up and cheer as
they defeat an advanced alien race
with...
VOICE (CONT'D)
A sheet.
Morse-Code.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Punching.
An Apple Powerbook 5300.
VOICE (CONT'D)
And Cousin Eddie.
Travel back to a time when summer
blockbusters were fun and
uplifting, not dark & Nolany.
VOICE (CONT'D)
In a movie that will trigger more 90's nostalgia
than the front page of Buzzfeed. Featuring:
VOICE (CONT'D)
R.E.M.
CD-ROMS
VOICE (CONT'D)
Data!
And Fruitopia.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Witness a film whose message of global unity...
... means only America can save the world.
VOICE (CONT'D)
And thrill at explosive action that casually
murders millions of people...
VOICE (CONT'D)
...But won't hurt this dog.
So this Independence Day, prepare to once
again relive the screen-watching...
VOICE (CONT'D)
the Sky-watching
And the speech-watching.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Hell yeah.
Starring...Jaden's Dad
VOICE (CONT'D)
President Lonestar
President Laura Roslin
VOICE (CONT'D)
Apple Genius
Crazy Dennis Quaid
VOICE (CONT'D)
Michael Buble Jr.
Not Jaden.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Nerdy Fabio
Her?
VOICE (CONT'D)
Vivica Not Actually a Fox
And The Best Extra Ever
VOICE (CONT'D)
Independence Day.
Can someone explain to me how they've already
made 3 Chronicles of Riddick movies and yet
I still have to wait til 2015 for a sequel
to this?